[Music]
as pandemic restrictions lift more and
more americans are venturing out of
their homes and
returning to their office jobs but some
black people have noted that
after spending the pandemic with their
families going back to work at their
predominantly white office jobs has a
certain
unforeseen difficulty let me explain
i get back to work it's been a year you
know that i'm feeling all right
excited to see my work friends even
though they're all white
i asked jill how her weekend was she
said oh i got sunburned
she asked me how my weekend was i said
you know a [ __ ] got turned
i could see it in her eyes she was so
surprised
she's got no idea what i said
i forgot how to code switch i wish i
could take it back i forgot how to cold
switch
what i said was just too black i forgot
how to cold switch i think i scared her
a little bit
i forgot how to go switch and all white
workplace just as [ __ ]
it ain't [ __ ]
[Music]
dude my white work friends are pretty
cool
but kevin's always trying to get smacked
talking about what's popping baby girl
even though i say don't talk like that
but it's been a year
i see him say it's been a minute what do
we do
i can see it in his eyes he was so
surprised
now he thinks he can talk to me any old
kind of way
i forgot how to code i wish i could take
it back i forgot how to code switch
what i said was just too bad i forgot
how to code switch
some people ain't got no class i forgot
how to code switch
i'm gonna end up beating his ass i'mma
beat his ass
[Music]
been in this pandemic for too damn long
hanging out
with my family so my blackness is strong
i can't remember
how i ever used to talk like i was on an
episode of friends ow
this whole song was just a joke if you
work at a place where you feel like you
have to code switch
just tell them don't go around and catch
these hands
i mean why wouldn't you they won't know
what it means anyway
i forgot how to code switch i wish i
could take it back i forgot how to code
switch
what i said was just in black i forgot
how to code switch
i think i scared him a little bit i
forgot how to code switch
and all white workplace just ain't [ __ ]
never that [ __ ]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
you